there's a lot happening here that you
can see
but there's also a lot of invisible
forces at play
that's true whether you're watching
naomi osaka at the u.s open or a match
at your local forks
so i'm not a tennis player but the grand
slams have always been a must-see and as
a scientist watching the pros play i had
this thought how do they hit the ball
with so much force at extreme angles
with incredible accuracy
all while keeping it in the court what
it comes down to
physics let's take a look in tennis
players leverage spin when they make
contact with the ball
specifically topspin
and backspin
[Music]
spin is exactly what it sounds like an
object rotating whether it's when you
throw a beach ball up in the air or hit
a ball in the tennis court so why does
spin affect the way a ball moves it's a
phenomenon known as the magnus effect
let's take a spin back in time to the
1800s and meet physicist hg magnus he
noticed that rotating cylinders moved
sideways when they were perpendicular to
the airflow some tried to take advantage
of that to move boats that didn't catch
on
for a more modern take let's flip over
to nasa where researchers have been
studying this these pictures were taken
in a nasa wind tunnel to demonstrate how
balls would spin interact with air why
was nasa playing around with tennis and
soccer balls
nasa isn't interested in aerodynamics of
sports balls nasa is interested in
aerodynamics of course because it
applies to airplanes and spacecraft and
sports balls are a good way to get kids
interested which is how this project got
started aerodynamics is the study of
objects moving through air and robbie
metta has been studying that since the
1970s to see spin in action let's go
back to the tennis court specifically to
a top spin serve or a quick serve as
they call it
let's zoom in see how the racket is
angled down when it makes contact with
the ball the balls propel toward the
other side of the court
that motion combined with the friction
between the ball's felt and the racket
strings gives the ball a gentle upward
tug making it spin up and forward
and what we're really interested in is
where does the smoke
leave the surface of the ball
that breaking point plus the combination
of smoke currents and the turbulent
wakes behind the ball tell the story of
topspin and backspin
so if the wake is deflected downwards
then there's an upward force
if the wake is reflected upwards then
there's a downward force simple huh
maybe for a nasa aerospace engineer i
stuck to biology for a reason let's go
over that force generation step by step
take a look at this forehand with
topspin
now look at this nasa image what
scientists are looking at is this point
right here it's the breaking point where
the air layer comes off
notice that the separation in nasa's top
spinning ball is not symmetrical on the
top side the air comes off earlier than
on the bottom
and it is that asymmetry that is key
to how
the magnus force is generated and it's
it's the same whether it's a tennis ball
soccer ball baseball what have you that
force comes from a difference in
pressure between the balls top and
bottom
for a top spinning ball the pressure is
greater at the top resulting in a
downward force
that force gives you the ability to hit
the ball harder and still make it in the
court you're leveraging the magnus force
and gravity to pull the ball down now
let's look at what happens during a
backhand with backspin or slice spoiler
alert it's the opposite
that pressure difference results in a
slight lift lift is that upward force
that robbie referenced earlier
let's look at a close-up of a tennis
ball with backspin to understand where
it gets its lift see how the separation
of the smoke or the wake is deflected
down
that got me thinking about isaac newton
and his laws of motion he watched tennis
balls and noted how their flight was
affected by spin in the 1670s long
before magnus was even born i guess he
was too busy discovering gravity and
devising our overarching laws of motion
to claim this phenomenon too still
there's no escaping isaac yeah so the
newton's law actually uh invoked in uh
when i said that if the wake is
deflected one way there's an equal and
opposite reaction in the other direction
so that's where newton's law comes in
and it's not just the flight of tennis
balls where this concept is critical
these principles apply to everyday life
lyft for example is critical for
airplanes drones and kites
you can even test this principle at home
with a beach ball
now that i understand how physics gives
tennis pros their edge i'm even more
excited for the us open while you're
watching keep an eye out for all that
spin and remember that you can
experience science anywhere you go just
like magnus and newton did remember
we're all scientists don't forget to hit
subscribe so you don't miss any of our
updates and if you're interested in
science and sports go over to wsj.com
i've left some links down below to get
you started hasta luego nos vemos pronto
gracias
you